it seems that naturally with human
beings just like you beautifully
described the history of this whole
thing
uh of it all started with the genes and
they're they're probably pretty upset
by the all the unintended consequences
that happened since
but the it seems that it kind of works
out like it's
in this collective intelligence that
emerges at the different levels
it seems to find sometimes last minute a
way to
realign the values or keep the values
aligned it's almost
um it finds a way like uh different
leaders different humans
pop up all over the place that uh reset
the system
do you one i mean do you have an
explanation why that is
or is that just survivor bias and also
is that different
somehow fundamentally different than
with the ai systems
where uh you're no longer dealing with
something that was a
direct maybe companies are the same a
direct byproduct of the evolutionary
process
i think there is one thing which has
changed that's why
i'm not all optimistic that's why i
think there's about a 50
chance if we if we take the dumb route
with um
artificial intelligence that that we
will human humanity will be extinct
in this century first just
the big picture yeah companies need to
have the right incentives
even governments right we we used to
have governments
usually there were just some king you
know who was was the king because his
dad was the king you know
and and then there were some benefits of
having this powerful
kingdom because or empire of any sort
because then it could
prevent a lot of local squabbles so at
least everybody in that region would
stop warning against each other and
their incentives of different cities in
the kingdom became more aligned right
that's that was the whole selling point
harare yeah noah harari has a beautiful
piece on how empires were collaboration
enablers and then we also
harare says invented money for that
reason so we could
have better alignment and we could do
trade even with people we didn't know
so this sort of stuff has been playing
out since time immemorial right
what's changed is that it happens on
ever larger scales right technology
keeps getting better because science
gets better so now we can communicate
over larger distances
transport things faster over larger
distances and the so
the entities get ever bigger but our
planet is not getting bigger anymore
so in the past you could have one
experiment that just
totally screwed up like easter island
where they actually managed to have such
poor alignment that
when they went extinct people there
there was no one else to come back and
replace them
if elon musk doesn't get us to mars and
then we
go extinct on a global scale then we're
not coming back
that's that's the fundamental difference
and that's the next
mistake i would rather we don't make for
that reason
in the past of course history is full of
fiascos
right but it was never the whole planet
and and then okay now there's this nice
uninhabited land here
some other people could move in and
organize things better
this is different the second thing which
is also different is
that technology gives us so much more
empowerment right both the good things
and also to screw up
in the stone age even if you had someone
whose goals were really poorly aligned
like maybe he was really pissed
off because his stone age girlfriend
dumped him and he just wanted to
if he wanted to like kill as many people
as he could yeah how many could he
really take out
with a rock and a stick before he was
overpowered right right
just handful right yeah now
with today's technology if we have an
accidental nuclear war between
russia and the us which we almost have
about a dozen times and then we have a
nuclear winter it could take out seven
billion people
or six billion people we don't know uh
so this
the scale of the damage is bigger that
we can do and if
if um there's obviously no law of
physics that says that technology will
never get powerful enough that
we could wipe out our species entirely
that would just be
fantasy to think that science is somehow
doomed not get more powerful than that
right
and and it's not at all unfeasible in
our lifetime that someone could design a
designer pandemic
which spreads as easily as covet but
just basically kills everybody
we already had smallpox it killed
one-third of everybody who got it
and and um what do you think of the
here's an intuition maybe it's
completely naive and this optimistic
intuition i have which
it seems and maybe it's a biased
experience that i have
but it seems like the most brilliant
people i've met in my life
all are really like fundamentally good
human beings
and not like naive good like they really
want to do good for the world in a way
that
well maybe is aligned to my sense of
what good means
and so i have a sense that the
uh the people that will be defining the
very cutting edge of technology
there will be much more of the ones that
are doing good versus the ones that are
doing
evil so the race i'm optimistic on the
us always like last minute coming up
with a solution so if
if there's an engineered pandemic that
has the
capability to destroy most of the human
civilization
it it feels like to me either leading up
to that
before or as it's going on there will be
uh we're able to rally the the
collective genius of the human
species i can tell by your smile that
you're
at least some percentage uh um
doubtful but is that could that be a
fundamental law
of human nature that evolution only
create it creates
uh like karma is beneficial good is
beneficial and therefore will be all
right
i hope you're right i would really
love it if you're right if there's some
sort of law of nature that says that we
always get lucky in the last second
karma but you know i
pref i prefer uh
not playing it so close and gambling on
that
and i i think um in fact i think it can
be dangerous
to have too strong faith in that yes
because it it um
makes us complacent like if someone
tells you you never have to worry about
your house burning down then you're not
going to put in a smoke detector because
why would you need to right
even if it's sometimes very simple
precautions we don't take them
if you're like oh the government is
going to take care of everything for us
i can always trust my politicians like
you know
we advocate our own responsibility i
think it's a healthier attitude to say
yeah maybe things will work out
maybe i'm actually going to have to
myself step up and take responsibility
and the stakes are so huge i mean if we
do this right
we can develop all this ever more
powerful technology and cure all
diseases
and create a future where humanity is
healthy and wealthy for not just the
next election cycle but like
billions of years throughout our
universe that's really worth working
hard for
and not just you know sitting and hoping
for some sort of fairy tale karma well i
i just mean
so you're absolutely right from the
perspective of the individual like for
me
like the primary thing should be to take
responsibility and to
build the solutions that your skill set
allows
yeah which is a lot i think we
underestimate often very much how much
good we can do right if the if you or
anyone listening to this
is completely confident that our
government would do a perfect job on
handling
any future crisis with engineered
pandemics
or future ai
people out there on on what actually
happened in 2020
do you feel that the government by and
large around the world has handled this
flawlessly uh
that's a really sad and disappointing
reality that uh
hopefully is a wake-up call for
everybody uh for the scientists for the
for the re for the engineers for the
researchers and ai especially it was
disappointing to see
how inefficient we were as
spread collecting the right amount of
data in a privacy
preserving way and spreading that data
and utilizing that data to make
decisions
all that kind of stuff
you